ça fait bizarre je m'étais imaginé julia
weston 15h manque c'est vrai que je me
sens un peu gêné c'est un peut de fait
je me reconnais pas dans la personne qui
est qui à gauche
sans me vanter je me reconnais
clairement plus dans la personne la
droite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas facile de militer pour le parti
reconquête il faut dire que depuis son
altercation sur le plateau de face à
baba avec alexis corbière stanislas
rigaud est devenu la cible des insoumis
vote ont enseigné en 2022
ce soir le porte parole de reconquête
stanislas rigaud témoigne de son
agression et dante fmp
merci à sa naissance rico d'être avec
nous et nous raconter ce qui s'est passé
et puis marc comolli qui fait toujours
des entrées
d entrée
globalement il ya une montée de la
violence partout en france pour tous les
milieux politiques mais nous parti shas
manche eric zemmour ce week-end par
exemple il ya d une famille d inaction
banderole avec ces mots qui se sont vus
aspergé d'essence et ces gens là ils
sont sortis de garde à vue donc les
personnes étaient interpellées et vous
savez ce qu'ils ont prises en plein
stage de citoyenneté pour avoir balancé
de l'essence sur des gens est en fait la
réalité c'est que tout est en train de
se tendre et ces gens là en fait dans
aucune limite et en fait ils ne se
sentent impunis et je crois que ces gens
là en fait sont totalement à l'opposé de
ce que nous on veut faire en tout cas
c'est à dire mais en fait profiter du
temps démocratique est une émulsion
présentiel pour discuter pour argumenter
deux minutes comme ça on va regretter on
sait que les autres ils ont un
vocabulaire qui l'ehpad comme le tien
mais toi tu cage on est insolent clara
kailash il a ça t'es tu fais quoi vous
appelez ça comment vous mais je
t'appelle ça toi comme vous mais moi
j'ai reçu un accueil pareil abonde jean
cassou tout le monde la racaille
l'étranger les six déjà comment tu veux
qu'ils sachent qu'ils ne sont pas ou qui
vont dans les plateaux ne vivent pas ce
temps quelqu'un mais quand tu fais bien
vous appelez ça comment vous des gens là
bas tu as
des femmes tu crois pas car un choc chez
les sérères comment mais j'ai un peu de
buzz pour rien non non il y avait deux
êtres pour un succès vous et crêpes
pourquoi ce soit vous moi le baj vous
êtes la proposition ces raretés pourquoi
je fais pas de buzz parce que si jamais
vous êtes président je vous prendrai pas
ici et mûri l'ennemi dont je me compte 2
milliards
racaille d'étrangers et d'eau les gens
ils nous les gens qui nous agressent la
seule différence cette fois c'est rangé
ses bases à comment capter chaque année
ça commence et les gens qui balancent de
l'essence sur des gens vous appelez ça
comment qui a balancé les sondages de
sol d'accord est ce que tu sais que
c'est d'essence était off non
les blés il a vu les premières
toutes les personnes qui détestent eric
zemmour qui vous voit c'est moi qui dois
je connais pas a dit mais ce n'est pas
tout les mois que j'aime pas qu'on est
pas traiter tous les gens qui regardent
la télé et qui vous voit ce soir se
distend fait finalement eric zemmour il
est vachement bien vous nous servez
merci de ce que vous faites parce ce que
vous faites là c'est une caricature de
vos propos et moi je sais très bien
c'est la preuve qu'il ya des gens en
france qui sont totalement au sol ils
sont totalement à l'ouest sur tout un
tas de sujets vous en faites
illustration parfaite ce soir au malawi
en tout cas invoquer touche pas que ça
marche comarco wts il ya un truc aussi
faut comprendre là c'est toi qui
apparaît d'étrangers directement moi je
suis désolé par dj turc l'adjointe au
moins les gens qui insultent des gens
qui les agréent ambiance de l'essence si
toi tu appelles passa des racailles tu
appelles ça comment si moi je fais des
potes dans la rue et les gens pour tous
les styles dir weh espèce donc tuer
alors là tu seras le connais des toiles
et des raquettes
plus important une
vingtaine parce qu'il ya une chose que
je vais te dire vous pouvez parler
pendant 25 ans le discours d'eric
zemmour et ton discours ils vont 0
t'insulte les gens n'en aurait pas
d'accord il faut dire ça c'est vous qui
a insulté les gens qui vont voter pour
lui et moi ils seront par millions
37 la folle soirée des miss a continué
avec ici on se rencontrer et d 23h38 on
a le droit à une belle réflexion
philosophique sur le romantisme partant
trop bien
ensuite à 95,3 en a fait la découverte
de pierre un gars un peu diffus
découvert que julien n'est pas comme sur
les photos mais qui à peine tenté un
petit compliment
avec des yeux bleus c'est faux il ya
[Musique]
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya eu l'émission
on a vu sur les réseaux il ya plein de
gens qui ont dit que vous aviez mis des
filtres et que voilà il est est ce que
vous avez été choqué par la tonalité des
messages alors j'ai regardé au début
ouais parce que on a un gros poids de
sap avec les personnes qui ont fait
l'émission avec moi donc un groupe où on
rigole bien et c'est renvoyer l'image
c'est au travail ont déjà j'ai vu
l'image ces faits n'ont laissé tomber ça
va pas être possible ensuite je me suis
quand même renseigné j'ai regardé un peu
sur m6 etc et
et là je tombe des nues parce que déjà
je vois le début de l' extrême mais pas
le son clairement je suis pas allé
jusqu'à la fin de l'extrait je ne savais
pas que mon image à lettres entre
guillemets ternie comme ça après je peux
reconnaître que la différence entre les
photos qui sont montrés à gauche et la
photo qui est montré qu'il monterait à
droite c'est vrai que c'est pas
ressemblant plutôt maintenant est-ce que
ça m'a vraiment touché non parce que en
fait je me reconnais pas dans la
personne qui est qui à gauche
sans me vanter je me reconnais
clairement plus dans la personne à la
droite plutôt que la wii même si cette
photo la date de 2018 je me reconnais
clairement plus ont été tournées quand
sa moye harmoye d'accord j'ai cru que
les téléspectateurs étaient violents sur
twitter j'ai trouvé son prétendant été
violent pardon mais quand une fille eric
vous avez un dec vous dites oh [ __ ]
c'est chaud c'est extrêmement vives y
avoir c'était et voilà regardez
voilà savoir à l'heure et
ça fait bizarre de voir un peu
bizarre je m'étais imaginé julian wilson
kardashian donc c'est vrai que je me
sens en plus gênés c'est un peu de leur
mac c'est pas ma fille des photos ça
vous fait c'est la première fois que je
vois les images c'est pour ça que
j'ai bientôt vous pouvez commencer c'est
drôle moi je trouve aussi c'est marrant
parce que voilà on a un bon feeling on
s'entend bien mouais c'est ça on se
plaît on s'entend bien voilà donc du
coup du coup
[Musique]
ne sont pas prises détrempée
non c'est resté pas tout bas non
d'accord
la télé ça reste la télé on est d'accord
que la réalité enfin vous voyez en face
surtout parce que voyez quand même que
je suis quand même un peu mieux et
je vous le confirme
confirme ils font clairement passé pour
larnack c'est laurent que vous êtes une
arnaque vous êtes mieux manager siècle
voilà l'arnaqué du siècle à il met en
bio un star voilà je pense qu'ils
mettent tout ça en scène parce qu'ils
veulent faire une émission agréable à
regarder ce qui est le cas mais il
oublie que ça peut être très violent
avec elle presque un million de
personnes qui regardent et je pense que
vous vous êtes fait défoncer sur les
réseaux et c'est très injuste est ce que
vous avez le sentiment ils ont truqué
déformer la réalité ouais clairement oui
après c'est c'est le sait c'est le jeu
est là j'ose le dire devant vous parce
que je les dis aussi à la productrice de
l'émission et j'ai été transparente avec
elle je lui ai dit vous m'avez
clairement créé des complexes que je
n'avais pas déjà je dirais pas pourquoi
il a dit au cul temps après ça regarde
m6 et c'est pourquoi ce nom ça c'est
regarder m6 maintenance et c'est une
très bonne qualité
parce que justement grâce il ya du
positif
après jour cyril on m'a déjà pas
respectées essaye de me respecter au dos
s'est déplacé je vais changer après le
travail j'aime rester camille palluel
parle de ton ami en fin de vie parce que
tu as c'est pas bon voilà c'est bon ça y
est c'est à dire [ __ ] je dis en fait
c'est quoi c'est mieux que
[Musique]
la
queen paul est avec nous je n'en parle
des proches de benjamin lundi que c'est
lui qui avait fait la première vidéo
avec
dans l'église cette vidéo qui nous a
énormément choqué mais qu'est ce qu'ils
ont ils vont nous dit quoi les veaux par
an cotisent ont vu cette vidéo mes
parents comme toute personne qui aura
des la vidéo ont été surpris et choqué
et j'ai quand même eu la chance d'avoir
des parents là pour moi et qui m'ont
soutenu comme d'ailleurs beaucoup d'amis
et
pendant un long moment savoir que j'ai
été j'ai coupé tous mes réseaux tous mes
contacts parce que j'ai vraiment besoin
de voir rayée de rien voir quand je vais
tous les jours sur twitter toutes les
applications ma tête me battais de bages
un partout j'en pouvais plus et depuis
plus de nouvelles de lui eux mêmes en
rien de ces sms
par rapport à celle que j'avais envoyé
par rapport à l'esprit mais la vidéo et
m'avait clairement dit que pour lui
c'est normal
qu'il savait ce qu'il faisait donc je
vois là et parasites une nouvelle
mathieu vous comprenez qu'on invite plus
benjamin va évidemment mais mais surtout
jusqu'au but de tout ça évidemment je
suis très choqué par ce qu'il a fait
mais je suis inquiet pour lui
aujourd'hui vraiment vraiment vraiment
ce que je pense que ça va mal se
terminer et je veux j'espère vraiment
pas ça va se terminer parce qu'il a 18
ans que c'est un gamin mais là la vidéo
victimes en sait bien que la montre pas
j'ai été extrêmement choqué et là il va
dans un niveau de violence et d'un
tsunami qui fait que 20 pour lui à moins
de sortir eux mêmes dans l'église a déjà
c'était inadmissible on a dit on parlait
du blasphème et drôle un système alors
que moi le risque existe mais je suis
contre tout ça est abattu me mayer 7
contre le contrat
mais je suis contre l'utilisation pour
blesser les gens tu veux dire que tu as
été instrumentalisée ta vidéo était
instrumentalisée à des fins politiques
c'est à dire car à miser pour visionner
par rapport au blasphème ou alors vous
n'avez aucune attention
choqués
non moi je suit les pas forcément mais
non franchement j'étais inconscient ce
jour-là est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
tenais vraiment à devant tout le monde
doit l'accepter gras et ça fait plaisir
de faire aujourd'hui ici de demander le
pardon parce que ça choque c'est
important et puis
je connaissais déjà un peu mieux que
nous quand même selon vous c'est quoi
son but et jusqu
alors comme je disais je te connais oui
et non un peu mieux que j'ai fréquenté
bien sûr
clairement c'est quelqu'un qui vit qui
disent allez tous à paris et
je pense que clairement il est perdu je
sais pas ce qu'il veut donner comme
image en tout cas moi ça au début on
voit pourquoi cette vidéo qui fait
actuellement honnêtement c'est qu'est-ce
qui fait ça me renvoie du dégoût et ce
qu'ils cherchent je pense c'est que il a
besoin d'attention c'est avec un data et
quand je vois tous ces personnes qui
réagissent tout le temps par rapport aux
benjamins savidan qui fait tous les
jours jeudi battant il ya encore des
gens qui râlent ça tous les jours cette
fois réagir c'est choquant mais c'est
son jeu en fait s'il a compris le
terrain qui faisait voilà moi j'aime
bien son comportement parce qu'il vient
il se désole tu te dis c'est fini avec
lui les jeux tu viens et tu demande
pardon et tu verras continuelle machin
faut pas trop je trouve un peu dur avec
lui
c'est vachement bien ce que tu as fait
la passe qu'il faut pas rester à côté
d'un mec comme ça parce que ce mec là il
va il va mettre la vie en danger faut
pas traîner avec un mec comme ça parce
que là il est en train de se mettre en
danger pour moi sinon il est très malade
il se met en danger était venu ce soir
on parle de lui et là où je rejoins
gilles secondes il faut pas l'inviter
faut il aura dû l'inviter j'ai l'idée on
aurait dû l'inviter si là il vient pour
son droit de réponse c'est très bien
maintenant je ne veux plus qu'on parle
de lui et moi je veux faire comme tu as
l'air toi je veux qu'on l'a on l'enlève
des réseaux sociaux oui mais là on
avance
on connaissait clash entre boubacar sy
ce qui a failli finir en octobre ou en
octobre cette fois ci c'est dans le
monde de la télé réalité que ça chauffe
ça va finir sur un an le mois dernier
dylan avait lancé un appel sur son
compte instagram pour trouver un
concurrent à sa hauteur pour organiser
un combat de boxe anglaise mon contact à
la fédération française de boxe m'a dit
que j'aurais pu faire un combat contre
un autre influenceurs juste dommage
qu'il n'y ait pas de candidat de télé
réalité à ma hauteur un appel auquel
influenceurs benjamin samata répondu
présent 10 26 je suis ton homme bambino
dylan n'a pas tout de suite que cette
réponse au sérieux les deux hommes vont
bel et bien s'affronter sur un ring le 6
avril prochain au palais des sports de
marseille merci à dylan et benjamin
d'être avec nous dit dan tu mesure
combien à m 86 ouais comme un kilo 74 et
toi benjamins 1 m 70 et pour combien de
kg 72 72 kg c'est vrai que c'est
nécessaire et alors où est ce que vous
vous entraînez vous vous en prenez la
formation si tu m'avais menti tu m'as
lundi que m 80
moi ça fait longtemps que je voulais
faire des combats de boxe ou est-ce que
malgré tout ça reste du sport bien sûr
ces deux fédérations françaises qui a
derrière c'est organisé il ya une
structure tout est carré que boxe
anglaise boxe anglaise vous vous
entraînez en ce moment ouais deux fois
par jour ou deux fois par jour quatorze
fois par semaine alors ça va ça commence
à apprendre ou pas ça va petit à petit
il ya un petit talon quoi un petit peu
ah oui ça doit pas y avoir la garde
c'est quoi le rythme la loi bon allez
pas mal c'est vrai mais c'est des coups
qui sont puissants comment tu te sens
très bien je suis chez moi tous les deux
mais pour moi c'est une pitrerie et
dj que tu consultes tu cautionnes pas la
boxe mais tu cautionnes quelqu'un qui
turque dans une église non déjà pas de
logique toi non aujourd'hui on utilise
notre air notre influence pour faire du
sport sur tu va concerner un mec qui
turque dans une église mais tu vas pas
cautionner de sportif qui monte sur un
ring bravo il ya aucune logique dans ce
que tu dis sportivement
c'est génial parce que ça sert de
l'ascenseur social
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
deck est venu mais
là je n'avais pas peur de vous deux vous
abîmez visage non ça c'est un jour hing
c'est que non bah oui mais c'est quand
même aussi beaucoup joué et sa plastique
c'est un chauffard risque aussi s'il ya
pas de plastique l'un pour les dons
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire une
petite démo pour voir un petit peu ce
que ça a donné les cours depuis l'élu
est-ce que momo tech et là nous avons
avec made in coach vas-y à l'hormadi
[Musique]
et
benjamin as tu veux nous faire une
petite demo
tech nazis alors il ya une différence
voir que d'abus de taille c'est
différent c'est que amar je n'avais
jamais fait de leçons avant le 9 mars
non mais je montre ce que je sais faire
mais j'ai commencé il ya deux semaines
d'accord ah oui c'est votre cours j'ai
coincé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis inquiet
je connais un petit peu voilà
la taille ou tard mois là il faut que
ton
olivier qui a été formidable puisqu'il a
fait venir anna avec sa fille ana qui
était en ukraine il ya une amie à elle
aussi qui va venir la semaine prochaine
je sais quoi y est vous dormez dans le
sur le canapé du salon dans ce monde et
ça voilà bon ça va ça va je connais bien
mon canapé bombe à travers ses olives et
c'est vous qui avez proposé c'est son
ami qui était un ami elle qui est abonné
ce qui est ukrainien dont qui
aujourd'hui se bat dans son pays qui lui
a dit on est en train de voir arriver
les premières bombes il faut que tu
parles olivier alors vous êtes venus ici
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a tous vu la
photo et sur les réseaux sociaux je leur
dis aux téléspectateurs ça a été un
déferlement oui ils accueillent anna
parce que c'est une belle fille voilà
donc et c'est vrai que ce soit olivier
je tiens à le dire il est très courageux
et il voulut il a dit moi je réponds à
toutes les questions se mettre fin à ces
polémiques parce qu'olivier il fait pas
du tout ça pour ça et s'il faut qu'ils
accueillent d'autres gens il accueillera
d'autres d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il est
en train de faire dans les prochaines
semaines mais gilles elle a posé une
question que c'est vrai que c'est la
question qui se pose sur les réseaux
sociaux vous pouvez leur poser à olivier
oui olivier autour de la vulnérabilité
de ces femmes seules ou avec des enfants
qui arrivent et on se pose tous la
question quelle est la réelle motivation
qui vous fait l'accueillir et
de vulnérabilité moi je trouve que là ça
c'est pas montès non mais c'est pas ça
le ton c'est pas la question c'est est
ce que est ce que voulait c'était une
amie elle c'était une amie lui c'est pas
il la connaît pas depuis juste js que
vous espérez initié une relation avec
elle voilà quel est le vrai but qu'est
ce que moi j'espère quelque chose de ça
moi je n'espérais simplement une chose
c'était aider une amie lui donne un
objectif à atteindre pour qu'elle se
sente bien aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle
se sent mieux de là à dire qu'elle se
sente bien
c'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas parce
qu'effectivement elle a de la famille
des amis des amis 6 bat etc etc c'est la
guerre ça se sentir bien on ne peut pas
baser une de toute façon enfin je crois
pas moins pas dans mon monde à moi une
relation sur ce genre de choses n'a
impossible il ya un an vacants agir
oui je voudrais dire quelque chose a
terriblement
c'est vrai que j'ai pas une tête
réfugiés mais j'en suis sûr
3 millions de fans nous avons
appelé au secours comment appeler à
l'aide
parce que j'ai joué
des photos pierre
j'ai vu que l'on plaisantait à ce sujet
certains commentateurs
permettait
de faire des
commentaires qu'ils ont faits concernant
l' avantage d'avoir des réfugiés de
jolis réfugiés j'étais terriblement moi
au départ ça m'a fait sourire on y part
ça m'a fait sourire c'est quand j'ai
compris derrière ce qu'il y avait dedans
dessous c'est à dire tous ses jambes
envoyez moi j'en veux cette pêche est
pas si c'est lui qui a commencé 7,7 ce
comics la ctu me reste là mais déjà bon
il utilise la photo comme photo de
profil donc moi je me réserve quand même
le droit de simplement de l'attaquer en
justice pour usurpation d'identité ça me
fait sourire mais je vais le faire comme
ça parce que je pense qu'il faut lui
donner une petite leçon il ya moi j'ai
simplement accueilli parce que c'est une
amie j'espère qu'elle ira bien et
surtout j'espère qu'elle pourra
retourner chez elle bien sûr parce que
c'est ça l'idée hélas le sait parce
qu'on en parle de temps en temps je n'en
suis pas certain voilà je n'en suis pas
certain j'espère que ça se passera bien
voilà je ne sais pas quels pays elle va
retrouver qu'elle apprécie si elle
rentre et c'est moi je lui ai aussi dit
que ma porte et j'ai ouvert ma porte
personnel était ouverte à toute sa
famille et à tous ses amis peu importe
si on doit être une dizaine dedans c'est
pas le problème voilà on tuera de la
place
[Musique]
cette année encore l'émission danse avec
les stars devrait faire son retour pour
une 12e saison le programme lancé en
2011 sur tf1 s'essouffle autant en terme
d'audience que de casting c'est pas une
mauvaise performance même si c'est ce
qu'on pourrait penser que la production
aurait donc décidé de casser la tirelire
en contactant la star des réseaux
sociaux nabil hargne et bien sûr quand
je fais pas manger je suis riche mais
selon public ces conditions et son
cachet ne serait pas si simple à
négocier l'affluence aux réclamerait un
million d'euros que les répétitions se
passent à son domicile à dubaï si elle
vient c'est pour sauver le programme qui
sans elle est mort déjà je sais pas si
on lui donne à la raison de prendre
exactement donc démarrer les exigences à
un million je pense qu à 800 milles ça
peut le faire il faut dire que 800
milles ce serait deux fois plus que
pamela anderson
elle ferait minimum trois semaines elle
serait sûr ne pas être éliminés et après
peut-être ajouter mais je sais pas si ça
allait plus loin il faut
compter
entre guillemets truqué c'est à dire
qu'elle est arrivé de faire trois
émissions mais comment ils peuvent
savoir si mabilat ils disent qu'ils
veulent assortir tout de suite mais il
faut dire hélas ce qu'ils veulent mais
moi je pense que la production ne peut
pas aligner un million d'euros le
maximum qu'ils aient fait ces quatre
cent mille euros un million c'est
presque le prix d'un prime donc c'est
compliqué moi j'ai eu thomas et nabila
cet après-midi ce qu'ils disent est ce
la marque et elle veut un million a
priori c'est plutôt la production qui la
veut elle a même pas eu de contact avec
la production pour l'instant accord et
elle a priori elle ne fera pas de mal
cette année parce qu'elle va accoucher
prochainement et préfère s'occuper de
son arrivée donc si elle le fait c'est
pas pour cette année c'est ce qu'ils
disent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]